was recently attending an event where I
was a closing keynote speaker and one of
the presenters before me was talking
about some comedy tips that you could
include and he did one of my biggest pet
peeves when it comes to other people
teaching comedy which has an end impact
on people learning comedy because
they've learned the wrong thing here's
my big pet peeve he talked about this
structure in comedy and it's pretty
commonly known but the structure goes as
follows it's a list of three things
where the third thing is unexpected so
it could be something like uh you know I
like to listen to podcasts at 2x speed
not only is it faster and more efficient
but also more people sound like me right
it's a list of three things that third
thing is a bit unexpected my pet peeve
here is that this person referred to it
as the rule of three this is actually
not the rule of three the rule of three
is simply that things in threes are
easier for humans to remember do you
know why because a list of three is the
minimum number you need to confirm
pattern because if you say something
once okay people kind of hear it if you
say something similar or connected to it
twice then people are like oh that's
similar to before but maybe that was
just an accident or maybe that's it you
do it a third time that completes the
pattern that says this was intentional
this is a grouping this is a set that is
the rule of three now in comedy there's
something called a comic triple which
takes advantage of the rule of three
which gives you a list right if we know
the rule of three so well and think okay
a list of three things is coming when
that third thing is unexpected we call
that a comic triple not a rule of three
so whether you are presenting or
learning comedy or just one another
technique for adding a little bit more
humor into your life know that the rule
of three is good in general broader
context great for creating cohesive
thoughts and ideas and specifically it's
called a comic triple when you're using
a list of three where the third thing is
unexpected to create that punch line